[Applause]
residents of Harrison shared Ukrainian
soldiers tore down Russian posters and
raised Ukrainian Flags
these verified videos posted online by
Ukrainian journalists and officials show
celebrations in her son after Russia
retreated from the city
just a few weeks earlier Russian
President Vladimir Putin claimed and
celebrated the annexation of Harrison
the only Regional Capital that Moscow
had captured since invading Ukraine in
February
the withdrawal from the Strategic
southern city is a major symbolic defeat
for the Kremlin we look back at the key
moments in how Russia captured and then
lost her son
this is the day when Russian tanks
rolled into her song the first major
Ukrainian City to fall during the first
few weeks of the war
[Applause]
but soon after the occupation local
residents came out and droves to protest
demonstrations lasted for weeks
and in some instances gunshots rang out
in the following months the Kremlin laid
out plans to turn her son into a Russian
city
the Russian Ruble became an officially
accepted currency and Russian
citizenship was fast-tracked for Willing
residents
by June Russian State media showed
footage of the first Herson residents
receiving their new documents
but around this time Washington started
shipping the first units of high Mars to
Ukraine these are long-range rocket
launchers and a game changer in the war
this enabled Ukrainian troops to begin
targeting bridges over the genepa river
which links Harrison to other Russian
occupied territories
as Ukrainian forces started retaking
parts of Southern Ukraine Moscow held
Sham referendums in harassan and three
other regions asking remaining residents
whether they wanted to join Russia
a few days later Putin signed treaties
to Annex Harrison and the other
territories and celebrations were held
in Moscow the annexation wasn't
recognized by any foreign government
apart from North Korea only a few weeks
after the annexation Russia began Mass
transfer residents from her son saying
up to 70 000 people would be evacuated
as Ukrainian forces Advanced toward the
city
Ukrainian soldiers also used artillery
to cut off thousands of Russian troops
in and around her son by targeting
bridges in the area
after Moscow said it had completed its
withdrawal Ukraine confirmed that its
troops had entered the city marking a
turning point in the war and a morale
boost for ukrainians
while the retreat is a political blow
for Putin Russia still controls parts of
the Harrison region and Moscow says it
will now hold stronger positions to the
east of Herson where it'll be easier to
resupply its troops as the war grinds on